jusqu'où ira le développement de Beauval
avec un cinquième hôtel inauguré
aujourd'hui la capacité d'hébergement du
zoo grimpe à 2000 couchages par jour
l'ouverture de ce nouvel établissement
baptisé les rivages de Beauval s'inscrit
dans une suite logique puisque le zoo
voit défiler un million 500 mille
visiteurs par an en moyenne seul 18%
viennent de la région Centre-Val de
Loire une affluence toujours plus forte
qui questionne sur l'impact du tourisme
sur la petite commune de
Saint-Aignan-sur-Cher et c'est seulement
3000 habitants reportage de Clémence
dosc
chaque année les 2 millions de visiteurs
du ZooParc de Beauval passe ou reste à
Saint-Aignan pour les habitants cette
cohabitation est prise avec plus ou
moins de philosophie on pratique quand
même la fréquentation des routes
nationales et routes départementales qui
se fait au mieux en attendant des des
modernisations
alors la circulation évite bouchée et
puis pour les gens comme moi ou d'autres
qui travaillent sur Saint-Aignan et bah
c'est compliqué quoi pour aller au
travail ou même pour faire autre chose
quoi racheter par le parc l'ancienne
hôpital de la commune s'est muet en
hôtel à deux pas du centre-ville plus de
structures pour absorber un flux de
visiteurs croissant le parc a accueilli
près de 80.000 personnes lors du
week-end de l'Ascension au point de
faire saturer la circulation alentours
et voirie des alentours et communes
n'ont pas et moyens forcément des
entretenir ça fait des années qu'elles
sont abîmées bien avant au développement
de bovailles donc chacun doit prendre
ses responsabilités chacun doit pouvoir
travailler ensemble dans le même sens
mais mais pour trouver des solutions
l'accès aux eaux est devenu un enjeu
préoccupant pour les deals de
Saint-Aignan en mai dernier il confiait
la Nouvelle République que sa commune
consacrée 200000 euros annuels à
l'entretien des voiries un discours
tempéré et une volonté affichée de
construction il y a un entonnoir au
niveau du pont de Saint-Aignan qui est
une départementale et nos touristes
empruntent les voies communales que ça
soit sur les communes voisines et à
Saint-Aignan qui ne sont pas adaptés
aujourd'hui pour accueillir autant de
voitures d'où la discussion et je
remercie vraiment Monsieur le Préfet qui
m'a assuré d'un rendez-vous avec la
Région le Département et à côté de
commune pour adapter les solutions non
pas simplement pour Saint-Aignan mais
aussi pour les communes voisines un
discours tempéré et une volonté de
construction le ZooParc reste la
locomotive économique et touristique du
département